you
[Music]
it is my pleasure to introduce Valentina
shin she is here to give a talk on
convenient and accessible audio-visual
media she's interviewing for puss off
position and so she could be finishing
up somewhere I think MIG and she's a
student at Friddle dress yeah and well I
will just lead it to her if you if
anybody has any questions you want to
chat with her later as well recognized I
think you might have a little bit of
time and we can set that up we're
already running a little bit late so
please thank you sigh and balan Tina and
I am currently a student at MIT and will
be graduating this June but I'm
originally from South Korea as well me
so today I'm going to talk about my
research which is looking at ways to
make creation and manipulation of
audio-visual media easier and more
accessible so why audio-visual media we
spend a tremendous amount of time both
as consumers of audio-visual media
looking at youtube listening to podcasts
or editing home videos and also as
producers of audio-visual media it takes
painfully long hours to create a good
quality audio or video and these are
some figures from my formative
interviews from some of my previous work
as well as research from other people
but we all know by experience that it
can take hours to create a good minute
of video or good quality audio it's
difficult for novice users but also for
professionals it's a labor-intensive
past those are so there's a lot to gain
by making audio-visual media easier I
think manipulating audio-visual media
should be as natural and simple as
writing with sketching so consider a
text document it's one of the most
accessible medium to deal with first of
all it's easy to navigate you can easily
skim or search through a document and
it's also straightforward to edit and
keep track of those edits and the
simplicity extends itself to
collaboration so that many people can
work on the same document at the same
time at ease and this ease of use is
what enables people to make new types of
media such as the wiki
millions of people contribute or online
to create a document that evolves over
time so my question is what does it make
to take to make audio-visual media as
easy and simple to create edit and
navigate so let's look at some of the
difficulties that we have a tall heels
enjoy media now first of all it's
difficult to navigate audio-visual media
is usually associated the time which
gives it a natural dimension so the most
natural way to navigate it is linearly
according to its timeline and that's
what the play button does but sometimes
we want so to speak unnatural navigation
like scrubbing through or jumping back
and forth to specific parts and right
now with the interface that we have
these are not as convenient as we'd like
to so both videos or waveform
representations of audio is not an easy
representation to skim or search through
the content another factor that affects
audio-visual media is its multimodal
nature so for instance in a video we
have the image frames we have the audio
sources and graphic elements such as the
subtitles and these elements are all
related to each other in the extra
dimension which is kind so editing one
modality has to affect the other
modality and this is true even for audio
sources without any image brains when
the audio contains multiple tracks
editing usually involves synchronizing
and aligning the different tracks so
operation on one of the track has to
assess the others as well so the
multimodal nature of media coupled with
time makes them a rich an attractive
force of data but it also makes it
difficult to operate on so in my
research I looked at ways to turn these
challenges into opportunities so I try
to take advantage of the
multi-dimensional a multimodal nature of
the of the media so more specifically
the different elements that make up
audio-visual media are related to each
other in space and time so a simple
example would be in a video adjacent
image frame tend to be related to each
other or an audio there can be natural
positives in between the audio which
gives us some natural structure so I try
to see where are the structure
to infer them and to take advantage of
them in my tools and secondly different
modalities of different potential to
assist user tasks so for example the
audio can be a good way of conveying
total new offices or the natural flow of
bounce but maybe a more static
representation like text could be better
for skimming or searching so we looked
at ways to use these complementarity to
reinforce user tasks and finally I take
a hybrid approach of mixing direct
manipulation with automation it's
important for users to feel that they
have direct control over what they're
navigating or editing but the automation
could help with the PDFs or repeated
parts of the pack so I'm going to share
with you today some of my work which
apply these approaches to specific
application domains these domains are
speech recording lecture videos and
presentations and the first area i will
talk about speech recording this is
based on a work that was presented at
the whisk constantly here and it's a
collaboration with low motley at adobe
so the task we're looking at is
authoring speech recording and here the
sun there are several parts to the task
one is working at the script the writing
and editing the script and the other
part is working with the audio recording
the audio and then editing it and in our
formative interviews we noticed that
this is not a straight for Dean your
task people go back and forth between
working with the script and working with
the audio and both evolved over time and
a major problem that makes the task very
difficult is that it's difficult to
iterate between the two of the scripts
and the audience so to begin with first
of all most existing tools don't deal is
both people typically write the scripts
in one application like Microsoft Word
and then we'll deal with the audio in a
different application like adobe
premiere of innocence scripting is done
with text now where is most audio
editing tools filled with audio
waveforms so there's extra work to
translate and relate one representation
to the other but most importantly we
noticed that the script and the audio
don't actually
match it's very common for people to
improvise during the recording but for
example here on the script the user
wrote there were many wars and fierce
battles but during the recording session
they improvise a little bit as day water
fierce battles continued on for ages and
there's a discrepancy between the two
now another common scenario is different
stuff and you're making a video for
paper submission you might just have a
simple outline in the script users
iterate back and forth but family in
your recording you expand on this part
and say typically users iterate back and
forth between the script and the audio
and finally you might not have a script
at all but just start improvising audio
and now some discrepancy is necessary
what happens now if I or my collaborator
wants to make detailed edits to the
wording of the audio it's not
straightforward first I have to listen
through the audio to know what's
recorded and then I have to mark the
place I want to we are headed by marking
either its pining or by transcribing
what was in the audio and then I would
mark the edit what I want to change in
the text and then I go through a similar
process to incorporate these edit I have
to re-record this portion scrub through
the audio define declining and then
carefully cut and paste in the new
version and as you can imagine these
tasks become more tedious if there are
multiple people working on the same
recording or if there's more discrepancy
between the script and the audio so our
goal was to design an interface that
integrates scripting audio recording and
audio editing as smoothly as possible
and the first key idea was to unify the
representation of the script and the
audio using text so we achieved this by
using speech to text automatic speech
recognition so with the advance of
speech recognition in general the idea
of using text to represent beach it has
been explored by previous researchers
but what's different here is that most
of these research focused on editing a
pre-recorded speech using its transcript
and in our case we wanted to also
include the scripting process itself
into the interface and how the script
editing audio edit
affect each other so the new idea that
we offer is instead of keeping a
separate representation for the script
and the audio transcript we merge the
audios transcripts into the script and
we call this the master document in our
interface so the master document will
represent both the audio that's being
recorded and the script that the person
has plans to record and all of these
will become more clear later when I go
through a demo so effectively this
merges the two modalities of typing the
script and recording the audio and
editing the text will affect the
underlying audio and recording the audio
will affect the update the master
document text now when the user reports
the audio we obtain the audio transcript
using speech recognition and we need to
somehow emerged this audio transcript
with the master document which will
contain the original script to begin
with and this is where the last key idea
comes in we provide an automatic
alignment algorithm to assist this task
of merging so before I describe in more
detail about how the system works let me
show you a demo of our system so first
of all this is what our interface looks
like on the left hand side you have the
master document and on the right hand
side is where the audio transcripts will
go and both are empty to begin missed
the user can start by writing the script
it can be a simple outline of bullet
points and then once the script disarm
the user can press report to report the
first take and the speech recognition
will process the speech and provide an
automatic transcript and the user can
record another take so so this is what
the interface will look like after I've
recorded three different tastes okay so
this is take one take Tuesday three and
each take is associated with the
recording each recordings are a common
form of communication in modern media
and what's not clear in this view is the
relationship between how the
chaska relates to the original script
but if I turn on the alignment our
algorithm aligns each segment of the
audio transcript to a segment in the
master script and it will also visualize
parts that are improvised in the audio
take and parts that are in the script
but was not recorded in this particular
on your cake and since I have multiple
tastes on based on the same script if I
go to the all tab it will summarize for
each section of the taste similar takes
of the same part of the script so I can
compare and choose and to compose the
final recording I can go ahead and
accept parts that I like from each tape
and this system will take care of
cutting the right portion and merging
them so here you see a part that has not
been recorded in any of the pics so let
me try to go ahead and record this take
we take advantage of automatic speech
recognition to transcribe speech
recordings into text and as the system
processes it also will try to align the
speech with the right portion of the
script I don't have to go ahead and so I
can just go ahead and accept it and
it'll put it into the right place you
can try to listen to some car audio as
completely separate entities we take
advantage of automatic speech
recognition to transcribe speech
recordings into tricks are interfacing
and go back to the presentation so here
is an overview of our system first of
all we have the master document which
functions as an enhanced edit text
editor that's coupled with audio and
when a user records of take we obtain
the audio transcript using speech
recognition and this transcript is
linked to the audio file specifically we
keep track for each word where the tours
and audio file the timestamp audio
transcript is linked to the master
document by a
the line at least each segment of the
audio transcript two segments of the
master document and if we record
multiple takes of the audio each audio
transcript isn't separately through the
master document and this alignment is
computed dynamically each time the
master document is updating for instance
if I want to assess a segment of the
audio transcript it will replace the
corresponding portion of the master
document link it to the audio source and
then we will recompute the segmentation
and alignment so let me point out a few
things about this alignment algorithm
which is the core technology enabling
the interface the big challenge comes
from the fact that I mentioned in the
intro that the script and the audio
transcript won't match exactly so there
will be parts that graphic respond there
will be parts that are improvised and
vice versa parts that are missing from
the audio another consideration we want
to take into account is the natural
structure in the speech so for example
in case of hypertext Essenes respecting
punctuation boundaries in sentences and
in case of spoken text sorry this means
respecting natural pauses and speech for
it and we have to take both of these
into account so for instance if we only
take into account punctuation this is
the segmentation you get and the left
hand side looks natural but on the right
hand there's an unnatural cut in the
middle of a spoken sentence so if we
were to merge this segment but then use
a different segment for the subsequent
part of the recording we will get evil
here and unnatural cut in the new
sentence on the other hand if the only
consider positive spoken speech we will
get in a natural cut in the middle of a
written sentence and finally our end
goal is to segment the two text and then
alignment so we want a consistent
segmentation between the two documents
and this can conflict with the earlier
goal of respecting natural boundaries so
let's stay here if we segment these two
texts according to their natural
boundaries this is what we did and since
the left hand side has two segments at
the right hand the audio speech is
consist of only one segment
because when you burst audio transcript
into the master document we can't decide
it's harder to decide which segment to
replace so since there's not a perfect
from alignment and match we solve this
as an optimization problem and designer
scoring function I won't go into the
details of the scoring function if so I
just want to point out that the first
term they are tries to separate
improvised segments from recorded
sections that have a crisp ondas and the
second term favorite segments at natural
boundaries filtrations and pauses and
the third term takes care of the
consistency between the two documents
the last term is just a normalization
term to prevent us from getting single
word segments as a result we get a
alignment between the two documents and
the algorithm can handle rough
correspondence and visualize
improvisation and unrecorded sections
and the group multiple paste from
different audio tapes so that the user
can compare easily and take the best one
so you download our system we conducted
two different types of user studies one
was a overall usability study and the
other was comparing it with a
state-of-the-art tool which was also
text based each editing and today I'm
just going to focus on the first of
these studies the user tasks here was to
create an audio recording using our
interface so we gave them a short
tutorial and articles that they were
going to create a recording about and
the users created a recording based on
this article and during this process
they were discouraged from just reading
out the article allow so that they could
go through their own scripting process
and the most exciting observation from
this study was that they went through a
very different workflow although they
had the same task and voice script was
able to support all of these different
workflows for instance in scripting some
people were would bite a very rough
outline of what they were going to
record whereas others would write a very
detailed script word for word and some
people did it write a script at all but
would improvise and then take that
improvised transcript as their first
draft of the script and then continue to
refine in recording
people used to record a portion of the
script at a time and then do another
take whereas others prefer to recording
tire scripts and then go on also for
editing some people like to record
everything and then merge them into a
final track whereas other people like to
merge portions at a time and mix that
with recording and also all of these
prophecies were not being here about
people went back and forth between
scripting recording and editing and
since our interface doesn't assume any
particular workflow it could accommodate
all of these different workflows
especially the master script played an
important role because it can
accommodate all stages of the script and
all types of scripts from details to
outline so let me summarize by going
back to the three principles I mentioned
in the introduction the important
structure for our task is the
relationship between the script and the
audio and the alignment algorithm is an
example of inferring and exploiting the
structure then we compute alignment you
take into account the natural structure
in the text and speech and then we
visualize them in a spatial way that's
immediately useful for the task of
merging the algorithm is an also an
example of using automation to handle
tedious tasks the most tedious part of
editing audio is aligning different
tracks cutting the right portion and
merging them in but now this is taken
automat taken care of automatically and
the user can focus on filling in the
content with the best take and finally
the master document is an example of
promoting synergy between two values by
unifying the and linking the audio with
the written text it's natural for users
to go back and forth between scripting
and audio recordings
the second domain I will talk about is
videos and in particular lecture videos
so this is a part of baseball work that
was presented at siggraph asia in claim
15 so here the past we're looking at is
watching lecture videos so let's say I
want to brush up on the fundamental
theorem of calculus so I found this
video from pan Academy let's watch a
little bit of the video hey I have some
function f that is continuous continuous
on an interval continues on interval
between a so I can watch the entire
video but what I'd really like to do is
find out what this video is going to
cover and then get right to the point
the fundamental theorem so in other
words I want to get a quick summary or
search for a specific point and in some
cases people prefer to read textbooks or
read the lecture notes because it's a
way for them to control their speed
where they can digest their content but
see what we can do with current
interfaces so I can scrub through the
timeline but this doesn't let me hear
the audio or see the images clearly i
can also randomly access point but again
i don't have a good sense of where in
the timeline to click so the information
that i want some platforms come with the
tool where i can choose the playback
speed but it still takes time to listen
through the entire lecture and also some
platforms provide interactive
transcripts and i can spin through the
transcript but this doesn't let me
compare the visuals clearly at the same
time all of these interactions are not
very efficient for what i want and it's
actually somewhat disappointing it seems
like at least in terms of functionality
the video browsers we use today are
pretty much similar to the video
cassette players who used in the
eighties when I think we can do better
so our solution was to design a
navigation or face that's more focused
on the content and if you think about it
let your contents are pretty different
from other types of movies you watch so
compare this movie
to this video of the vocal yeah so it's
very different so first of all the
visuals are very static and lectures
they are drawn continuously but once
they're drawn and appear on the board
they don't change or move about and the
audio content consists almost entirely
of speech which is also closely related
to the visuals on the board and finally
lectures tend to present information in
a linear fashion so our interface is
based on these characteristics and we
transform the video into a more readable
format that resembles lecture notes
here's a demo of what it looks like
first of all here's a screenshot of the
original video the final screenshot of
the blackboard and then here's what it
looks like after the transformation so
our interface on interleaves text with
figures from the video and some of the
text is hidden by default and pressing
this button will bring up some of the
text that is hidden and you can also so
you can read through the interface but
you can also play the video by clicking
on any part of the image or the text
this right over here is the graph of y
the video will play in line d now our
lower endpoint is a so that a right
Andrea what it's like so the video plays
in line on the figures and it will
continue on to the next figure so
there's the visual transcript is
generated automatically given an input
video and it's transcript and there's
two parts extracting the figure and then
it's structuring the text into short
paragraphs and hiding some parts of the
task take text so I'm going to go
through just to point out a few parts
about each of these tasks so the
challenge in extracting figures is that
they are drawn nonlinearly in space and
time and this video will illustrate that
but here notice how the user goes back
and forth between working on the
equation below and then annotating the
diagram of off-planet eating and working
on the equation and again in this case
he's annotating the equation drawing
some diagrams going back to cilenti
space and then working on the first
diagram as well so the figures are drawn
on your knee in both time and space we
look at this as a segmentation problem
and again we saw it as an optimization
you design a scoring function that takes
you to account both the temporal and
spatial characteristics of the drawings
but for instance how come packaged
figure is what is the temporal and
spatial gap between the figures so on
and so forth and here's a screenshot of
the previous video and this is what the
visual transcript output looks like
sheer the instructor draws the diagram
and then works on this equation and then
goes back to the diagram so we separate
the two stages of the diagram so that
each step is clear and in the second
stage we only highlight the new parts of
the diagram which are the airline for
audio analysis we exploit the temporal
crisp honest between the drawings and
what the instructor speaking so when the
instructor speaks and writes at the same
time they tend to be speaking about what
they're drawing so here he say let's say
I have some function s that is
continuous on a neutral zucchini and B
which is what he actually drew at the
same time and when he is talking by not
writing at the same time extends to be
something that explains the drawing your
connection so here he's explaining that
the graph he's going to draw next is the
graph of F and he just explained and
likewise while he's trying to graph he's
just explaining the drawing so from the
temporal correspondence we divide the
sentence into two parts one that is
explaining the figures and it's like
kind of redundant and the other that
connects the figures and reinforces
explanations and by default we hide the
redundant descriptive sentences
behind it figure which can be expanded
than the user wants here's a few more
examples of visual transcripts we tested
our algorithm on 20 different videos
from 10 different authors to make sure
that the algorithm can accommodate
different authors file chain summarize
we propose visual transcript as a
convenient way to search skin and
navigate lecture videos renew spatial
and temporal structure to extract key
figures and organize the text into
paragraphs and to remove redundant texts
you make use of different modalities so
by using a static arrangement of figures
and text we make it a readable format
where it's easy to skim a search but
also people can go back and forth
between reading and watching the video
and in this case all the process of
generating was done automatically in the
user only interact with the final output
the final domain is about presentations
and this part is a sneak peek into
current work in progress so we do
presentations all the time like I'm
doing now and the two most common type
is doing slide presentations or working
with blackboard or chalkboard so this is
a photo of john reed one who's a
physicist to popularize the term black
hole and his style was to fill the
blackboard with diagrams before the
lecture angle student so she was an
exception and that he used the
chalkboard kind of like a powerpoint but
usually a typical black for self
presentation would look more like this
it's more improvised if we compare the
two styles of presentations the slide
presentation takes more time to prepare
and it is more polished rest rockport
presentations can be done with less
preparation beforehand but it does
require more effort during the time of
the performance the advantage is that
you can be more flexible to interact
with the audience and accommodate their
needs so and that for that reason it's
arguably more engaging so what we aim to
do in our current research is to take
the best of both worlds we want to
develop an interface for presentation
that is flexible but also helps people
during the performance not to have too
much cognitive load and existing tools
allow users to mix the two styles by
allowing people to ink on top of flight
but we feel that they don't address the
challenge that presenters have when
they're writing on the fly we don't just
want to enable presenters to write on
top of ice but we want them to write
well and writing well on the fly is
difficult because first of all it's
difficult to remember what's right and
it's also difficult to plan the layout
on the fly so where to put what but even
if you can do both remember and lay it
out it's hard to execute your plan on
the fly because sometimes you're writing
might become too big and you run out of
faith or your writing might get slanted
and also because you're talking at the
same time and finally there are things
you cannot plan ahead so if you want to
add extra content and response to an
audience questions or things like that
so our approach is to assist writing on
the fly meaning in two ways first by
dynamically managing the layout the
users can adjust the layout on the fly
and then also by taking advantage of the
prepared compound here's a demo they
must take some aspect of these ideas
okay so the left-hand side is the
speaker view and the right-hand side is
the audience view and you will notice
that some parts some of the parts that
are in great here are not shown in the
audience view and unlike a traditional
presentation you don't have to decide
the order of what will be shown and you
can just be more flexible with to show
or things on shore hi things on the
slide that's one aspect of being
flexible but another part is when
writing for instance I want to write
this i can write very big or small and
as you notice on the right hand side
it's being fitted in real time to the
box that i had planned
and let's say this is a lecture about
the binary search tree and say I talked
about all of this and one of the
questions came up there how do you
define a height of the tree so I want to
make some room to explain that I'm going
to meet some room here did you find the
height is it going to work ok so it's a
little slow right now but if it's a work
in progress but it'll make room for an
extra thing so i can write high is path
from root to leaf ok again it'll fit
into the right place and you can imagine
things like here I can try to draw a
bunny and people will not notice that
I'm tracing on top of an image and
sometimes very good funny drawer or
things like that but going forward you
want to look at ways to be more
predictable with layout management right
now they're just using a lot of
optimization to do the layout and also
looking at ways to beautify the writing
in different ways by taking advantage of
us prepared below cup PowerPoint
software all right maybe start
huh
hmm
[Music]
okay so I started with a broad goal of
making audio-visual media as natural and
easy as writing or sketching and I
looked at three specific application
domains where we can facilitate user
tasks by really taking advantage of the
specific workflow and the
characteristics of each media and moving
forward my long-term vision is to enable
anybody novice users professional users
or people with disabilities to create a
manipulate audio visual medium and
achieving this goal will have
challenging problems in user interface
design and data representation and
structure so continuing to improve
usability for single users are very
skill levels as well as supporting
communication and collaboration for
multiple users will be both critical and
the three principles that I refer to
previously can also be revisited through
the lens of how they can empower users
even further so for example but take
advantage of temporal and spatial
structure I mentioned in the beginning
of the talk that audio-visual media is
difficult to navigate so like photos
which can be viewed at once audio-visual
media you need to actually navigate
through the media to look at all of its
contents and if the user is familiar
with the source to begin with this can
be easier because they can take
advantage of their unique knowledge but
in for example if multiple people are
involved this is more difficult because
you're dealing that they source that has
been edited by someone else or you have
not altered in the first place so people
need a better way to navigate
audio-visual media forces people
sometimes use simple tricks this is a
photo from Udacity recording studio and
when the instructor makes a mistake
during the recording they would press
this spell which has a unique sound
profile and alerts the video editor
later on which which places to look out
for so in our work on speech recording
interface we also looked at ways for
through different representation text
representation and visualizations align
things
and chewiness side by side all as a way
of making it easier to navigate a source
and this also helps people we originally
had a single user in mind but this also
helps people to collaborate
asynchronously and I want to look at
ways to use this type of structure
inside the tools to help people navigate
India in a smart way secondly take that
advantage of multiple modalities so as I
mentioned different modalities have
different potential to assist users task
we saw for instance how static
representations can facilitate video
navigation or how text representation
can facilitate speech editing a similar
principle applied on the side of
interaction for instance professional
users may be more efficient and using
keyboard shortcuts or navigating
complicated menus but novice users may
benefit from a natural language
interface that interprets day commands
and likewise different modes of
representation and interaction can
benefit people with different levels of
skills and finally taking the hybrid
approach of mixing automation with
direct manipulation and this is not new
at all it's one of the reasons we use
computer but I think there are major
challenges specifically in the
audiovisual media domain and one such
challenge is developing personalized
automation so people with different
skills are accessibility any different
type of automated assistance and in each
case automation should be as flexible as
possible for user input at various parts
of the process and currently most of the
automatic algorithms provide very
limited control for the user for example
by setting parameters in the beginning
but there are many ways to make that
more flexible empowering users to work
effectively on audio-visual media in an
easy and natural way but also enable
them to create new types of media that
was not possible before and through new
ways of working so today I shared with
your first step towards this goal
through novel interfaces that address
challenges in specific domains and I
would like to make real impact by
creating efficient tools for various
different types of media
and finally before I open up the
questions I would like to thank all of
my colleagues and mentors who I was very
fortunate to work on seamless thank you
the question yes okay I really feel like
the voice characters I hate that fresh
presentation I record then I listen my
I'd lived in this major grade so County
use it for one but what I'm going to do
in addition to the audio is take about
the PowerPoint viduals as well as
scheduling the bills and from the slide
transition and if you thought about and
creating that into the void script yes
workflow that because then automates or
no spills happen or a happy boy activate
those those right right that's
interesting so while the motivation
behind the project was for recording
lecture videos but we did have visuals
in mind but we narrowed down and focus
on the speech part there are many parts
of fits dealing with slide presentations
you can definitely think about
activating the animations with the voice
if you have a script in mind but also if
you are saying recording a lecture video
and drawing the animations there was an
interesting people people who are
interviewing where some of them were
making these lecture videos and one
strategy there was this is hard to draw
any nation and speak at the first time
in the first round they would record the
speech and they would just scribble
around on the blackboard and then they
would go and edit these scribbles later
on here I think also the physical part
is tiny of the animation and mashing de
with the script so some way to decouple
that and make automation make us take
advantage a lot of nation to take care
of that would be a good thing and also
being able to edit parts of the
animation going back without affecting
the timing of the transcript you see
another vision yeah so that's an
interesting problem
Sargon you mentioned the when you were
discussing the video transcript that one
of your goal with searchability hmm if
their plans are already the
functionality for keyword search ability
some of those transcripts look really
long one wanting to find one okay right
so right now it's just simple use the
ctrl s and search if you search your
website I can imagine there can be
different visualizations to summarize
all the parts with these keywords or
look at all the figures that are related
to these keywords it's not implemented
yet but it's definitely a possibility
yes I mentioned that for the conference
open business conference for all their
videos that they post afterwards they do
a keyword visualization for every video
you navigate it up an early that way
through this cloud of skewers parts
about the linear timeline so having a
pair of England here at searchable for
cloud or rank list of keywords poker
anyone gunnin for their job work on
ahead social keeps navigate the videos
for them both use it for a really
popular video I think even get there are
lots of people have how many times fine
you know the seem like point of
nutrition and sugar around a lot five
mins eventually you're all going to like
narrow as some wasn't eight points in
this period we need to select that there
wasn't any more thought on that with you
hokan he works on look videos in
particular and he had an idea of looking
at these data from looks where people
view most frequently where the people
thought and had a different timeline
that had some friction so that people is
navigate or on be able to see okay what
do other people view most and where are
the important part parts and things I
thank you with the video Chester mm-hmm
can you hear any through evaluation
afterwards like having students nor
watch the videos that interface for
smaller new faces so we did a
comparative study using the YouTube
interface most standard one and there
was a different work that was summarized
blackboard by electro videos by taking a
panorama of the blackboard and providing
a separate transcript and there what we
looked at was two things one which
interfaces best for searching and which
is good for summarizing the lecture
video and for the search path we look
the truth are actually three different
types of questions one was visual search
things you could search by just looking
at the figures the other was textual
search for having to look listen to the
audio and the other was on contextual so
people had to see both the visual and
the text and relate them to get the
question so we would come up with
questions from the different type of
search questions and compare them
it's just a follow-up on that project
hmm what are you doing anything with
with a time to txt record of the boxes
issues not the life for itself there's
there's there's information you might
want to search up what is what you don't
want I mean you're gonna have a stake in
this record 9-2 dragging a battle we
thought about it but we didn't go
through that now he felt like most of
the text is also represented in the
transcript so they were say things out
loud if they're doing but it is and it
would be another interesting area where
you can really reduce redundant
information from the transcript in audio
and also have a better way of unifying
the two modalities where that's probably
more important for prepare powerfully
where you often don't speak out right
there blackboard you you're often saying
what you're writing mm-hmm I can imagine
it I think it powerful here much more
often it's your they're continually be a
little bubbly also like another
interesting but related problem there
what we scored was looking at and
biggest pronouns because in the
blackboard they would say things i go
here look at here this part of the
diagram so what we tried to do there was
localize the pointers when that word was
a touring and tried to annotate the
diagram using like ABC so figure 2a is
what this person same and here so that
was on an area we did explore yeah
yeah well thank you very much thank you